حسب وسائل اعلام تركيا فان قلعه غازي
عنتاب التاريخيه تعرضت لاضرار جسيمه بسبب
مركزها الذي عرضها بشده للزلزال في منطقه
بازارجيك في كهرمان مرعش تعرضت ايضا قلعه
حلب لاضرار منها سقوط اجزاء من الطاحونه
العثمانيه وحدوث تشققات وتصدع وسقوط
لاجزاء من الاسوار الدفاعيه الشماليه
الشرقيه كما سقطت اجزاء كبيره من قبه
مناره الجامع الايوبي وتعرضت تواجهه
التكيه العثمانيه لاضرار ظهرت ايضا تصدعات
وتشققات على واجهه المتحف الوطني في حلب
في حلب الشهباء ايضا المدينه القديمه
تعرضت لانهيارات وتصدعات في الكثير من
المباني القديمه السكنيه وسقوط عدد من
ماذن الجوامع التاريخيه حماك ذلك طالتها
اضرار الزلزال في حي الباشوره التاريخي
حيث دم واجهه احد العقارات القديمه
الاثريه في مدينه السلميه افادت التقارير
عن سقوط الجزء العلوي من ماذنه جامعه
الامام اسماعيل
وشهدت اجزاء متساقطه من الجدران الخارجيه
لقلعه
[موسيقى]